women like men that just get it you know
like
you don't want to tell guys how to solve
that problem you don't want to solve the
problems for like women aren't generally
King makers they want to be with a king
you know what I mean like they want to
be with a guy that's that's got it
figured out so when it comes to that
feeling emotions or being vulnerable
your dog dies be emotional you know you
lose your parents fine be emotional it's
required you have to grieve through that
part Brenda from accounting was mean to
you today you don't want to hear about
it I mean personally for my friends if
Brenda at accounting was mad mean to one
of my girlfriends I'd be like [__]
get over it but most women would want to
have a big conversation about that let's
get together we'll pour some wine let's
bust out the cheese get The Chicory
board going let's you know let's talk
about Brenda and what a [__] she is
sort of thing
what about just being
hurt
absolutely but but I mean the point that
we're making about this about this
concept is that women want men to just
get it and it's okay to be vulnerable in
certain circumstances it's okay to cry
in certain circumstances that are
warranted but most men get emotional and
get vulnerable and cry over the littlest
things which turn women off you know men
don't understand this that they want
women want men that just get it that are
competent that can solve problems that
can get things done that can make it
rain they don't want to deal with a
crybaby you know one of the things you
hear a lot of women say and um you know
after I got divorced I was dating a lot
of divorced women as well because I was
you know looking at women around my
stage same age group and one of the
questions I was always asking so why did
you get divorced so what happened and I
heard a lot of oh you know he was a big
baby he couldn't keep a job down he was
such a [__] he wasn't a man he was a
big beta you know big cry baby you know
like all of these things and it's like
huh that's interesting but who was the
guy that you mayor worried right like
you know did something change and one of
the things that happens to men in
long-term relationships I've noticed is
this this concept that I call the
Pacific it's it's the it's the
betatization through a thousand
concessions you see what I'm saying so
it starts with something like hey Rich
you know don't brush your teeth over
there you're going to get toothpaste on
the carpet then it goes to make sure you
put the white socks in the white hamper
and the black socks and the black camper
then it goes on that one just makes
sense let's go vegan together
and then it's and then it continues to
go concession after concession after
concession sure sure and the and the
thing is is that women truthfully they
don't want men to make that many
concessions I understand the organized
part like I understand you know the
laundry thing and all that sort of stuff
but as soon as you start stamping
everything yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes and then you give her the stamp
and she starts stamping everything yes
her interest in that guy declines
dramatically agreed because here's the
deal he doesn't know who the [__] he is
right and you why is it like a girl to
not know who the [__] she is either like
don't you want a girl to contest with
every now and again don't you want a
little bit of a challenge I mean you
know there there there's like a perfect
ratio it's like a one to five ratio I'm
trying to think of it's a Hoffman no
it's um
um trying to think it's a marriage uh
couple that's researches marriage but
there's a perfect ratio of disagreements
that need to happen in a relationship
and you know I don't know what your
thoughts are in Jordan Peterson but
he'll talk about that too you don't want
it easy you want some level of challenge
that is required for the relationship to
be strong you don't want to push over do
you do
I I don't want to come home to a
disagreeable bossy [__] woman
I want to come home to a loving woman
of course a woman wants a loving man but
you don't you
tell me that you do
sessions for you
still respect her
I would
for what
because she's not a man
and women are different remember that
you know we talked about that before men
and women are different just because you
want see I think the great lie that a
lot of women have subscribed to when
they're drunk on this Kool-Aid is
they've been told to behave like men oh
you have to be somewhat disagreeable you
have like there's a certain ratio
because Jordan Peterson that's not true
that's not true
is it it's not true that's just called
autonomy
is it though yeah absolutely because no
two people are identical right but it's
not like we could all just agree on
everything so just like you're gonna
know who you are and I would know who I
was like you're not always going to
agree so you can respectfully disagree
or you can have the discussion change
your mind perhaps I actually like part
of doing this interview is I was hoping
you could change my mind on some things
because I think because then I know I've
learned something
because I'm I'm open-minded that's
that's like the fascination is that cool
teach me something new but I know I have
my convictions about myself I know who I
am and I'm not just going to bend over
in every single category so a man can
feel good about himself or so he cannot
be challenged yeah but believe it or not
it's he's not he's not trying to feel
good about himself by not arguing with
you he just doesn't want to argue with
you he just wants peace in his life
right now I get that not many men are
competent and deserve a peaceful life I
understand that there's a lot of losers
out there a lot of weak men that get
challenged by women for a reason I get
it I fully understand that but a guy
like me I I don't want a confrontational
woman in my life right it's it's not
needed and it's unnecessary and I'm
competent enough and I'm successful
enough and influential enough that I
don't need to put up with that sort of
thing so while I get that a lot of women
have told have been told to be strong
and independent and decisive and you
know to some agree like women I think
today are more disagreeable than they
ever have been in history yeah but I
don't think that it's because we're
being told to it's because we are it's
because people are getting more
confident with who they are
well it's because women don't need men
anymore nobody needs anybody
don't they
do they I don't know that's a great
question what's the point of a
relationship what's the point I love the
question what is the point of being in a
relationship you're essentially talking
about not being challenged but my
experience and all of the people that I
know and the books that I read and the
shows that I watch relationship is the
greatest place to grow because it's
going to challenge you it kept but not
because of the challenge having
challenged it like I have challenges in
life Danica I run businesses I have
Investments I have real estate I you
know I have supercars that break down
all the time like I have enough
challenges but nothing Taps into your
emotions like a relationship no no
that's wrong men successful men that are
doing something with their life do not
want disagreeable women in their life
they want a compliment to their life
they want a woman that adds value to
their life they don't want to fight and
argue over well this weekend we're going
to go shopping for curtains and they
have to look like this and it's like
after I've just been busy all day doing
all this [__] putting out fires you're
going to yell at me about curtains now
oh yeah I mean that's a shitty challenge
that's a shitty challenge that's what a
lot of guys are dealing with though
the real challenge is the getting
triggered part the real challenge Danica
there there are good relationships out
there where there aren't constant
challenges there aren't constant
disagreements there's there's there's a
there's a compliment to one another's
lives sort of thing
um one of the things that I wanted to
mention as well too because you brought
up Jordan Peterson is
you know I think he does more good than
he does harm and I I think you've had
him on a podcast have you yeah yeah so
um you know he's an interesting guy but
I think that he gets marriage wrong I
think he gets relationships wrong
um there is an advertisement that I saw
on the daily wire and they were pumping
out this thing about Jordan Peterson's
three-part series on on marriage and I
thought that's interesting because I
have a chapter in my book on why smart
men don't marry anymore so so I went and
bought you know the subscription I
watched it and I did a video podcast on
it um you know you can go find it on my
podcast channel the unplugged Alpha but
the thing that he gets wrong is that his
entire notion about a good marriage
about a good relationship by the way
he's only had one okay his entire notion
is built around negotiating in that
relationship and what you're basically
talking about is negotiating desire all
I'll do the chore play I'll do the
dishes put them away take care of the
laundry run the kids to the soccer meet
and swim lessons all that sort of stuff
uh and I need you to do the you know
this that and the other thing sort of
thing it's like you know you sort of
start negotiating back and forth with
this and that or I'll give you this you
can hang up that picture if I give you
these curtains sort of thing and it's
like he wants to continuously encourage
guys to negotiate in a relationship and
I don't think that that's
that's a good idea because you can't
have a good relation trust me because
I'm in one right now you can have a good
like I've been in [__] relationships
where you're constantly fighting and
there's all this you know head butting
sort of you know I was married to a
lawyer like I've like I've dated a lot
of successful women okay
um you know lawyers accountants you know
stuff like this so you can be in a good
relationship and not have to negotiate
anything in the relationship she has
genuine burning desire for me right and
I feel the same way about her and it's
organic and I don't have to fight over
anything like that
um he doesn't even talk about basic
concepts like vetting women for marriage
like let's take a look at any red flags
that might exist in her life that we
might not want to invite into our life
to complicate it unnecessarily so you
know like his stuff is pretty good and
he definitely does more good than bad
but I I really think he gets like this
notion of just ramming men into the
slaughterhouse of marriage which is what
happens to most guys believe it or not
here are the stats so
um they've done these surveys and
over an average I think it was 8.1 years
take a guess how many couples were still
in love you know defined as in love like
what percentage 30 13
13. take take a guess how many to find
the relationship as Blissful like we're
blissfully in love like three percent
exactly that that's bad that's terrible
that's horrible [__] is wrong and and
why would you as a guy sign up for
something that would look like marriage
girl you are acting like it's only guys
that are miserable I'm not saying it's
just guys but but the risk factor that
most guys have which is exclusionary to
you because you're successful in your
own right from your own career but most
guys like Kevin from you know the VP
Department of the uh sales team
conveniently almost always you know
we'll be making 280 000 a year will
conveniently marry you know Becky who's
a 40 000 year hairdresser right so the
risk for guys is they're getting
themselves into a situation or an
environment where it's now their entire
wealth and their Futures potentially and
access to their kids if they have them
because women still get the vast
majority of custody orders is very very
high risk and potentially low reward for
them in a marriage but for women it's
high reward and low risk because they
get the custody because they are always
taken care of with family law because
they can pull the false domestic
violence trigger sort of thing so
there's a lot of moving parts to this
that most women don't get until they
finally get sort of thing right and I'm
not saying that any of this you know
needs to change we should rally troops
or anything like that
again I'm the enjoy the decline guy
right so I'm just like you know drop
perimeter watch them do what they want
to do and I'm going to protect mine and
you know there's Us Versus Them sort of
thing so it's it's a very interesting
Dynamic when you take a look at it for
what it really is you know like we said
earlier you know there's truth and lies
so what's the point of a relationship
well the point of marriage if we're
gonna bring it to well you don't believe
in marriage though right no no okay and
I'm totally like I have been questioning
that Institution for years now like do
you really need marriage to make this
thing real I mean well the thing about
marriage that most people don't know
there's a really good book by Stephanie
Koontz called the history of marriage
you should check it out
um and the tldr version of it is that
the reason why we've been getting
married for you know hundreds of years
and all this sort of stuff ever since
the Advent of Agriculture and all that
is the acquisition of in-laws right so
I'm successful as a farmer my brother is
a blacksmith my other brother is a
teacher my dad is a law enforcement guy
your side of the fan family you got a a
chemist you got somebody that's uh you
know mob boss like you know like you
would you would blend the families and
you would then have the acquisition of
in-laws and guess what now you're taking
care of your own but that's changed and
that was where it was Community Based
where it was like now it's the state
that is the head of the household right
yeah the family is no longer the head of
the household the man is no longer out
of the household the state is the head
of the household and in fact you could
argue that women have all the power with
the state behind them because of the way
that family law is written and the
advantage of being the mother and
usually being the lower income earner in
most relationships I guess again with
the exception generally of somebody
successful and accomplished as yourself
sort of thing so you know what's the
point of marriage today I don't see any
point in it right you know if my
girlfriend said well if we don't get
married then I'm going to leave I'll
just okay it was nice knowing you right
like I like I am I I have to surrender
to that fact because I've acknowledged
that it's it's too risky and it's too
difficult for me to go through that
again right now do you want to have kids
I think that a two-parent household is
the best way to do that do you need to
get married to do that not really can
you get married if you really want to
um can you lower the risk by vetting you
know the you know who's going to
potentially be the mother of your kids
can you you know there's lots of things
that you can do to sort of improve the
odds of not throwing your life down the
toilet bowl so to speak but you know
we're in a very different and difficult
time when it comes to both the Sexes
like I understand men's point of view
very well and talking to you about this
you know from the female you know
perspective I get that you say certain
things and and why you say them but
again I still think that men and women
are better together than they are apart
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out